Narrator: TONIGHT,
SPECIAL GUEST SHARK BILLIONAIRE
CREATOR OF THE GoPro CAMERA,
NICK WOODMAN,
RETURNS TO THE TANK.
I THINK THIS IS AWESOME.
Narrator: IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESS.
OH. OH, YEAH.
SWEET!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
YOU HAVE GOT SOMETHING HERE.
[ CAT MEOWS ]
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
THIS IS LIKE
THE ULTIMATE TOY TO ME.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
OH, COME ON!
THIS WILL GO GREAT ON QVC.
OH, MY GOD!
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
JUST LIKE THAT, BOOM!
O'Leary: I CAN'T DECIDE IF
THIS IS NUT BAR FACTOR 6.2
OR YOU HAVE SOMETHING HERE.
SO DISAPPOINTED IN YOU
RIGHT NOW!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY
IS A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE SELLING A
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN, RENOWNED
BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND NICK WOODMAN,
CREATOR OF THE GoPro CAMERA,
TURNED HIS PRODUCT INTO
A CONSUMER AND MEDIA EMPIRE
WORTH MORE THAN $8 BILLION.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A REIMAGINATION
OF A 5,000-YEAR-OLD INVENTION.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DAVID PATRICK,
AND THIS IS MY BUSINESS PARTNER,
ZACK FLEISHMAN,
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
SEEKING $100,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5% OF
OUR COMPANY, SHARK WHEEL.
THIS IS THE WHEEL,
AND IT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR OVER 5,000 YEARS.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
THE CURRENT WHEEL
HAS MANY LIMITATIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE,
THIN WHEELS ARE FAST,
BUT THEY DON'T GRIP WELL,
AND WIDE WHEELS GRIP,
BUT THEY'RE SLOW AND HEAVY.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE ONE WHEEL
THAT JUST DOES IT ALL?
AFTER 5,000 YEARS,
I THINK WE DESERVE AN UPGRADE,
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY, NO ONE'S
BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE IT OUT,
NOT EINSTEIN, NOT DA VINCI,
AND NOT EVEN YOU,
MR. WONDERFUL.
BUT I DID.
I REINVENTED THE WHEEL,
LITERALLY.
I CAME UP WITH A MATHEMATICALLY
BALANCED DESIGN
THAT'S BASED ON A CUBE.
NOW, I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA THINK,
"HOW COULD A DESIGN
BASED ON A CUBE EVEN ROLL?"
BUT TAKE A LOOK.
WE DISCOVERED THAT NOT ONLY
DID OUR WHEEL ROLL,
IT ROLLED BETTER
THAN A TRADITIONAL WHEEL.
WE CAME UP WITH A WHEEL
THAT'S FASTER,
HAS MORE GRIP, LASTS LONGER,
AND GOES OVER
VIRTUALLY ANY TERRAIN.
BUT WE WOULDN'T BE NAIVE ENOUGH
TO SHOW UP WITH JUST AN IDEA.
WE STARTED OUT
TO PROVE OUR WHEEL
WAS THE BEST BY GOING INTO
ONE OF THE LARGEST CONSUMER
WHEEL INDUSTRIES,
SKATEBOARD WHEELS,
AND THE SHARK WHEEL
IS WINNING RAVE REVIEWS.
OUR WHEELS ARE FASTER,
HAVE BETTER GRIP,
AND ARE SMOOTHER OVER ANY SORT
OF PAVEMENT,
SOMETHING NO OTHER WHEEL
CAN DO.
BUT THIS IS JUST ONE OF
THE INDUSTRIES THAT WE'RE IN.
THIS IS
OUR SKATEBOARD WHEEL.
THIS IS THE WHEEL THAT WE'RE
SELLING WORLDWIDE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ONE OF THE FASTEST WHEELS
ON THE MARKET.
COMING UP NOW
IS OUR MID-SIZED WHEEL.
THIS IS ON A STROLLER.
IT MAKES THE STROLLER
EASIER TO PUSH.
NEXT UP, THIS IS
OUR LARGE-SIZED WHEEL.
THIS GOES ON ANY TERRAIN,
THROUGH SAND, THROUGH MUD,
THROUGH GRASS,
AND IT JUST LOOKS AWESOME.
SHARKS, I WANT TO WELCOME YOU
TO WHAT IS NOTHING LESS
THAN THE REINVENTION
OF THE WHEEL.
IS THIS FOR REAL?
Grenier:
CAN I GET UP AND PULL IT?
ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
BECAUSE WHEN I WATCHED HER
PULLING IT...
IT LOOKS WOBBLY.
...IT LOOKED TO ME -- RIGHT,
IT LOOKS WOBBLY,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT ACTUALLY
DOESN'T GLIDE SMOOTHER.
O'Leary:
LET ME TRY THIS ONE.
AND IT...
I MEAN, IT'S BIZARRE.
BUT, ACTUALLY, THIS DOES FEEL
VERY, VERY, VERY LIGHT.
David: PLEASE, GET ON.
I JUST HAD MY ACL REPLACED.
FEEL THIS.
AS MUCH AS I WANT TO RIDE
THAT THING...
WELL, YOU KNOW, I HATE TO,
LIKE, BE A KILLJOY,
BUT AS I PUSH THIS,
IT'S GOING LIKE THIS.
THAT'S A PROTOTYPE.
WE DO HAVE TO, UNFORTUNATELY,
EXPLAIN FOR THE TREAD ON IT.
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE THAT IS
OUR PRODUCTION WHEELS
ARE THE SKATEBOARD WHEELS,
AND I DEFY ANYONE
TO GO ON THOSE
AND SEE ANYTHING
OTHER THAN PERFECTION.
YOU UNDERSTAND, THOUGH, WHY
WE'RE TESTING THESE, BECAUSE --
ABSOLUTELY, AND I WANT YOU TO.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE'RE --
TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
IS A BIG THING.
WE'RE SUPER PROUD
OF WHAT WE ARE.
WE KNOW THIS IS
OUR MARQUEE PRODUCT
THAT WE'VE ALREADY
FLESHED OUT,
AND WE'RE READY TO GO
INTO THESE.
WE'VE GOT BIG DEALS WORKING.
I'M DYING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
HAVE YOU BEEN
SELLING ANYWHERE?
YES.
WE'VE BEEN SELLING THE WHEELS
WORLDWIDE THROUGH THE INTERNET.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
DOES THE WORLD NEED
THIS SOLUTION?
THE BIG PREMISE OF YOUR
PRESENTATION WHEN YOU CAME OUT
IS THAT THE 5,000-YEAR-OLD WHEEL
IS DEFECTIVE IN SOME WAY.
YEAH.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THE REGULAR WHEEL,
BUT THERE'S MILLIONS OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF WHEELS.
THE GEOMETRY OF OUR WHEEL
GIVES US THE EQUIVALENT
OF A SKINNY TIRE
WHEN IT'S JUST RUNNING
ON A HARD PAVEMENT
BUT A FAT TIRE
WHEN IT STARTS TO SLIP.
WE LAST LONGER,
AND WE'RE FASTER.
THIS SHAPE, ONE LITTLE SHAPE,
IT'S A PERFECT CIRCLE,
A PERFECT SPHERE,
A PERFECT CUBE, A SQUARE,
AND, YOU KNOW, A SIGN WAVE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS,
WHO CARES?
OKAY, WELL,
IN THE SKATEBOARD INDUSTRY,
THERE'S A NUMBER-ONE THING
THAT HAPPENS.
HIT A ROCK,
YOU'RE GOING OVER IT.
WOULD YOU NOT GO OVER
IF YOU HIT A ROCK WITH THAT?
NO ROCKS, NO PROBLEM.
WE JUST GO RIGHT OVER THEM
LIKE BUTTER.
John: HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS?
ARE YOU A SCIENTIST OR...
I HAVE NO DEGREES.
I HAVE NONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WOULD NORMALLY LEAD YOU
TO BE WHO I AM.
NOT A PROBLEM.
BUT IT ENDED UP,
THIS HUGE IDEA HITS ME.
DAVE, THE SALES SO FAR
ARE BASICALLY ON THE SKATEBOARD,
RIGHT?
YES, 100%.
THIS IS OUR FIRST PRODUCT
THAT WE CAME AND MARKETED.
AND HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE'VE SOLD OVER 4,000 UNITS
OF JUST OUR SKATEBOARD WHEEL.
HOW MANY DOLLARS IS THAT?
THAT'S $183,000.
REALLY?
IN FOUR MONTHS.
John: HOW MUCH ARE YOU
MAKING THEM FOR,
AND HOW MUCH ARE YOU SELLING
THEM FOR?
MAKE THEM FOR $12,
SELL THEM FOR $69.
THE MEATIEST PART
OF THIS IS,
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
INDUSTRIAL USES.
BUGABOO STROLLERS
CAME TO US.
WE'RE DOING A DEAL
WITH RAZOR SCOOTER.
I CAN'T DECIDE IF THIS IS
NUT BAR FACTOR 6.2
OR YOU HAVE SOMETHING HERE.
I DON'T KNOW,
BUT HERE'S HOW I'M GONNA
STRUCTURE THE DEAL
TO REFLECT MY CONCERN
THAT YOU'RE A NUT BAR FACTOR
6.2, ALL RIGHT?
'CAUSE THIS IS DEFINITELY
A ROYALTY DEAL.
HERE'S HOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU $100,000.
YOU'RE GONNA PAY ME 10%
OF REVENUE
UNTIL I MAKE BACK $500,000,
THEN THE ROYALTY DISAPPEARS.
BUT TO KEEP ME ENGAGED
AND IN LOVE WITH YOU,
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME 2.5%
OF THE COMPANY TODAY.
THAT WAY, I CARE ABOUT YOU
AT LEAST A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OFFER.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
SO, THIS COULD BE GREAT.
BUT I GOT UP,
I WHEELED THEM AROUND,
BUT THEY WERE A LITTLE WOBBLY.
ALSO, WATCHING THEM,
KIND OF DIZZYING FOR ME.
I AM OUT.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU.
John: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M WHERE KEVIN'S AT.
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS ARE EITHER
CRAZY OR GENIUSES.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000 FOR 20%,
AND I'LL TAKE OVER
ALL THE LICENSING FOR YOU,
BUT CONTINGENT ON YOU
SHOWING ME REAL PAPER
FROM THE COMPANIES YOU MENTIONED
WITH REAL OFFERS,
AND I WILL PUT MY LICENSING
DIVISION TO WORK.
I HAVE NO CONTINGENCIES.
YOU'RE EITHER NUTS,
OR WE'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY TOGETHER.
BUT I'M GONNA GO TO WORK.
BUT HE WANTS HIS MONEY BACK.
I ALWAYS WANT
MY MONEY BACK.
OKAY, SO, I WILL OFFER YOU
100 GRAND FOR 15%.
HOWEVER, MY CONTINGENCY IS,
I NEED TO HAVE
A COUPLE OF MY BUDDIES
TAKE THIS THING FOR A RIP
DOWNHILLING,
AND IF THEY SIGN OFF ON IT,
THEN THAT'S MY DILIGENCE.
SO, YOU HAVE THREE OFFERS.
ONLY ONE HAS NO CONTINGENCIES.
WE DO HAVE INVESTORS IN.
WE'VE RAISED $603,000
TO DATE.
AND WHEN WERE YOU
GONNA TELL US THAT?
NOW, THREE OF THE INVESTORS CAME
IN AT A $10 MILLION VALUATION.
Grenier: SO, YOU HAVE
THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE.
John: MY B.S. METER IS GOING
THROUGH THE ROOF RIGHT NOW.
YOU'VE ALREADY RAISED MONEY.
YOU DIDN'T TELL US
TILL THE LAST MINUTE.
YOU GOT SO MANY PEOPLE
AROUND YOU,
I'M GETTING SCARED RIGHT NOW.
SO I'M TAKING MY OFFER
OFF THE TABLE. I'M OUT.
JUST LIKE THAT, BOOM, GONE!
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAVID AND ZACK HAVE TWO OFFERS
FOR THEIR REINVENTION OF
THE WHEEL, THE SHARK WHEEL.
KEVIN'S OFFER IS $100,000
FOR A 2.5% STAKE,
PLUS A 10% ROYALTY
UNTIL HE MAKES BACK $500,000,
AND NICK'S OFFER IS $100,000
FOR A 15% STAKE.
SO, AS OFTEN HAPPENS
IN THE SHARK TANK,
THE WATERS CAN GET CHOPPY,
AND I THINK,
BECAUSE I'M INTERESTED
IN THIS --
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
CUBAN'S DOING YET --
I'M GONNA REACH OUT TO NICK
AND SAY, "HEY, LISTEN,
YOU KNOW,
RATHER THAN COMPETE WITH YOU,
WHY DON'T YOU JOIN ME
IN MY DEAL?"
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
WE'RE GONNA NEED 5% EQUITY,
2.5% EACH, 'CAUSE I KNOW
HE WON'T GET UP EITHER
UNLESS HE GETS AT LEAST 2.5%.
SO, BUT I WOULD DO IS PROVIDE
A LITTLE BIT MORE DOUGH, OKAY?
RAISE IT UP TO $150,000.
WE GO 50/50 IF YOU'RE ON BOARD
FOR THIS, 75K TO YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
I LIKE THAT.
I'LL DO THAT DEAL.
YOU'RE COMING IN WITH ME
ON THIS?
I'LL COME IN WITH YOU
ON IT.
ALL RIGHT, WE GOT TWO NOW.
Cuban:
WHAT IF I CAME IN, KEVIN?
WE CAN DO IT THREE WAYS.
DEFINITELY.
LET'S DO IT THREE WAYS.
THAT WAY,
THERE'S NO COMPETITION.
ALL RIGHT,
NOW YOU'VE GOT THREE SHARKS.
HERE IS HOW IT'S GONNA WORK.
$225,000 FOR 7.5.%
OF YOUR COMPANY.
WE'RE GONNA SPLIT IT THREE WAYS,
2.5% EACH.
THE 10% ROYALTY REMAINS IN PLACE
UNTIL WE'VE RECOUPED $500,000,
WHICH WE'RE ALSO GONNA SPLIT
THREE WAYS.
A VERY SIMPLE DEAL FOR YOU
TO DECIDE ON RIGHT NOW.
DEAL.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE WANTED.
[ GRENIER LAUGHS ]
AND LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING, GUYS.
THAT IS THE DEAL WE WANTED.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ SHOUTS ]
I JUST LOVE, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
DOING DEALS WITH YOU GUYS
BECAUSE IT CLOSES
WHILE I'M STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE DAMN STRUCTURE.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHAT WAS THE DEAL AGAIN?
WE JUST WENT
INTO THE SHARK TANK.
WE TOLD THEM THAT WE REINVENTED
THE WHEEL.
WE GOT CALLED
A LITTLE CRAZY,
BUT WE WALKED OUT
WITH THE THREE BEST PARTNERS
WE COULD'VE EVER HOPED FOR.
Narrator: THIS SEASON,
WE'VE SEEN "SHARK TANK"
REACH AMAZING NEW HEIGHTS.
WELCOME TO THE WHITE HOUSE!
Michelle Obama:
MY HUSBAND AND I ARE THRILLED
TO CELEBRATE WITH ALL OF YOU
AT "SHARK TANK."
O'Leary:
WITH "SHARK TANK" AND THE WHITE
HOUSE WORKING TOGETHER,
WE CAN INSPIRE A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION OF ENTREPRENEURS.
YOU GUYS HAVE HIT THE BIG TIME.
THIS REALLY SHOWS YOU
THE POWER OF "SHARK TANK."
IT'S JUST AN AMAZING
AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY.
EVEN YOU COULDN'T HAVE PREDICTED
THIS KIND OF BREAKOUT SUCCESS.
NO, BUT IT'S TAUGHT
ALL OF US
WHAT A PLATFORM
"SHARK TANK" IS.
IT'S PROVEN THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS STILL ALIVE.
I HEREBY PROCLAIM TOM + CHEE DAY
HERE IN THE CITY OF CINCINNATI.
Man: IN THE YEAR LEADING UP
TO "SHARK TANK,"
WE'D DONE A MILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
BEEN TWO YEARS NOW, AND WE'VE
GROSSED OVER $14 MILLION.
Man #2: SINCE WE DEBUTED
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO,
WE HAVE GROSSED OVER $10 MILLION
IN SALES.
Man #3:
NOT EVEN A YEAR LATER,
WE HAVE OVER $6.5 MILLION
IN SALES.
Woman: WITHIN JUST 10 MINUTES
ON QVC,
WE SOLD OUT OF ALL 32,000 UNITS.
WE'D LIKE TO MAKE A FINAL OFFER
IN THE AMOUNT OF $14.5 MILLION.
THE GrooveBook DEAL
IS THE LARGEST DEAL
EVER IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY.
IT'S A DREAM COME TRUE.
THE MATCH FOR A SMALL BUSINESS
IS BRINGING IN THE RIGHT TEAM.
Man: NOT ONLY HAVE OUR SALES
BEEN GROWING
BUT OUR TIPSY ELVES TEAM
IS, TOO.
WE'VE HIRED TWO NEW DEVELOPERS
AND A TEAM OF INTERNET
MARKETING CONSULTANTS.
Man #2: WE HAD TO MOVE
INTO THIS NEW FACILITY.
WE WENT FROM 8 EMPLOYEES TO 32,
AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO HIRE
A LOT OF VETERANS,
SO WE'RE PRETTY PROUD OF THAT.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY TOGETHER.
ABSOLUTELY.
Man #3: "SHARK TANK" HAS CHANGED
OUR ENTIRE BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT JUST OUR BRAND. IT'S
SUN-STACHES ALONGSIDE MARVEL.
IT'S AMAZING.
WELCOME TO THE MOUNTAINS!
"SHARK TANK" PROVES THAT
IF YOU HAVE A GREAT IDEA
AND YOU'RE WILLING
TO WORK LIKE CRAZY,
YOUR DREAM COULD COME TRUE.
Woman: I AM BEYOND THANKFUL
FOR MY "SHARK TANK" EXPERIENCE.
IT HAS GIVEN ME THE ABILITY
TO BUILD THE COMPANY
I'VE ALWAYS SEEN IN MY HEAD.
Boy: SEEING MY BOW TIES
IN NEIMAN MARCUS
MAKES ME FEEL LIKE I'VE ARRIVED.
SINCE COMING ON "SHARK TANK,"
EVERYTHING HAS CHANGED
IN MY LIFE.
Man:
I GET TO DO SOMETHING I LOVE.
I GET TO MAKE FAMILIES
INSANELY HAPPY.
I TRULY DO HAVE ONE OF
THE BEST JOBS IN THE U.S.
Man #2: WE'RE LIVING PROOF
THAT THREE GUYS WITH A DREAM
AND AN IDEA CAN GO A LONG WAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Woman:
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD.
WE CHASED OUR DREAMS, AND NOW
WE'RE SEEING THEM COME TRUE.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL FEELING.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A UNIQUE
BUSINESS FOR ANIMAL LOVERS.
[ CAT MEOWS ]
AWW!
THAT'S...PRETTY CUTE.
[ CAT MEOWING ]
Grenier: OH.
[ CAT GROWLS ]
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ADRIANA MONTANO,
AND I HAVE A CATLICIOUS IDEA
CALLED GATO CAFé,
AND I'M SEEKING $100,000
IN EXCHANGE OF 20%.
[ CAT MEOWS ]
IMAGINE GOING TO A CAFé
JUST TO READ A BOOK,
HAVE A CUP OF COFFEE,
AND HAVE A KITTY ON YOUR LAP.
WITH GATO CAFé, I CAN MAKE
THAT DREAM A REALITY.
I KNOW [LAUGHS] YOU MAY THINK
THIS IDEA IS CRAZY,
BUT, ACTUALLY, CAT CAFéS ARE
POPPING UP ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
I WANT TO OPEN THE FIRST
CAT CAFé IN FLORIDA,
WHERE, EVEN YOU, MR. WONDERFUL,
CAN COME IN,
HAVE A CUP OF COFFEE,
AND RELAX FROM YOUR BUSY DAY.
OUR PATRONS CAN ENJOY ALL
THE BENEFITS THAT CATS PROVIDE
FROM THEIR ENTERTAINING
PLAYTIME ACTIVITIES...
[ TSKING ]
...TO THEIR ABILITY TO IMPROVE
OUR HEALTH AND REDUCE STRESS.
SO, SHARKS,
WHO'S MY PURR-FECT PARTNER?
[ CAT MEOWS ]
ARE YOU GONNA PASS AROUND
THE SAMPLES?
ABSOLUTELY. HERE.
[ CAT MEOWING ]
KITTY, KITTY,
KITTY, KITTY.
THIS ONE IS BARBER.
BARBER?
YES.
HEY, MAN.
THAT ONE IS PLUCKY.
[ PLUCKY MEOWS ]
AND THAT ONE THAT YOU'RE
HOLDING, LORI, IS SALON.
THE MAMA
IS CALLED SCISSORS.
[ MEOWING ]
SO, WHERE ARE THESE GATO CAFéS
GOING TO BE?
SO, ACTUALLY,
IN BOCA RATON, FLORIDA,
IS A VERY DIVERSE AREA.
SOUTH FLORIDA --
YOU HAVE FORT LAUDERDALE.
YOU HAVE MIAMI.
Woodman:
NOT GONNA HURT HIMSELF.
HE'S A KITTY.
HE CAN JUMP.
Cuban:
YOU KNOW WHAT?
HOPE YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
BEYOND YOUR WILDEST DREAMS,
BUT I'M OUT.
YOU'RE OUT?
I'M OUT.
JUST BEFORE YOU SAY "OUT,"
THOUGH,
BEFORE ANY OF YOU SAY "OUT,"
THESE CATS ACTUALLY
ARE RESCUE CATS.
THEY'RE ALL GONNA BE UP
FOR ADOPTION,
SO YOU'RE NOT REALLY
TELLING ME "OUT."
YOU'RE TELLING THEM "OUT."
I LOVE YOU, KITTIES,
BUT I'M OUT.
WHAT FLOOR OF THE BUILDING
WOULD THIS CAFé BE ON --
GROUND LEVEL OR HIGH UP?
I SURE HOPE GROUND LEVEL.
I MEAN, IT'S FLORIDA.
YOU CANNOT REALLY HAVE
THAT MUCH.
I WAS JUST THINKING,
IF IT WAS HIGH UP,
YOU COULD OPEN THE WINDOW.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
A CAT PROBLEM ANYMORE.
OH, KEVIN!
I AM SO DISAPPOINTED
IN YOU RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY
WITH THIS?
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO PAY
TO COME INTO THE CAT CAFé.
THERE IS A FEE TO ACTUALLY
SPEND TIME WITH THE KITTIES.
[ CAT MEOWS ]
SORRY, THEY'RE SO CUTE.
[ LAUGHS ]
HOW IS IT DIFFERENT THAN, LIKE,
A PET STORE OR, YOU KNOW...
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY GET
THE CHANCE TO SIT DOWN,
HAVE A CUP OF COFFEE,
A BAKED GOOD, YOU KNOW?
John:
HOW MUCH IS THE ENTRY FEE?
$9.
[ WHISTLES ]
ALL RIGHT.
Grenier: SO,
DO YOU KNOW THE NUMBERS?
O'Leary: ARE THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS HERE IN AMERICA
REGARDING SERVING FOOD...
YES. YES, THERE IS.
...AROUND ANIMALS
ROAMING FREELY?
Grenier:
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
YES, THERE IS,
AND IN FLORIDA,
A FOOD ESTABLISHMENT
IS NOT REALLY CONSIDERED
IF IT ONLY SERVES BEVERAGES
AND PREPACKAGED FOOD.
HOW MANY SQUARE FEET
IS THIS STORE?
WELL,
I DON'T HAVE A STORE YET.
THIS IS JUST A CONCEPT.
YOU WANT TO HAVE A CONCEPT
WHERE RESCUE CATS...
YES.
...WILL BE IN ONE PLACE
AND PEOPLE CAN COME IN FOR $9
AND SPEND TIME WITH THE CAT,
MAYBE HAVE A DANISH AND A COFFEE
OR A GLASS OF WINE.
MY QUESTION IS,
WHY WOULD SOMEBODY
PAY TO DO THAT
WHEN, TECHNICALLY, THEY COULD GO
TO AN ANTI-CRUELTY SOCIETY
AND ACTUALLY SPEND TIME
WITH THE CATS THERE?
OH, 'CAUSE THAT'S NOT A VERY
NICE ENVIRONMENT TO GO.
NO, IT'S NOT
A NICE ENVIRONMENT, BUT...
NO, IT'S VERY DEPRESSING.
YEAH.
I HAVE FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN AN ANIMAL NONPROFIT
SOLELY DEDICATED TO CATS.
WHAT I'VE LEARNED THERE
IS THAT 70% OF CATS THAT GO
INTO SHELTERS GET KILLED.
SO THIS WOULD BE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
IN A FACILITY
WHERE THE ANIMALS
ARE GONNA GET KILLED.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE GOT
SOMETHING HERE.
I THINK THIS IS AWESOME.
I'VE GOT THREE BOYS,
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY ANIMALS
IN THE HOUSE.
AND THEY WOULD WANT TO GO
ALL THE TIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE MOST VIEWED
VIDEOS ON YouTube ARE?
KITTIES.
YEAH.
YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
NUMBER-ONE-VIEWED VIDEO
ON THE GoPro CHANNEL?
A FIREMAN SAVING A CAT.
John: WHETHER I'M PROUD
OF IT OR NOT,
I ACTUALLY REPRESENT A CAT
NAMED TARA THE HERO CAT,
AND TARA THE HERO CAT
BECAME A YouTube SENSATION
FROM SAVING A LITTLE BOY
FROM GETTING MAULED BY A DOG.
THERE ARE A LOT
OF THESE POPPING UP.
A PAID PROGRAM LIKE THIS
IN JAPAN IS HUGE.
THESE THINGS
ARE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
IN CALIFORNIA, THEY'RE OPENING
THREE THIS YEAR, SO --
THREE CAT CAFéS?
MM-HMM, YEP, THEY ARE.
BUT THE CHALLENGE HERE
THAT I SEE IS,
YOU DON'T HAVE
AN ESTABLISHED PROPERTY,
SO AS AN INVESTOR,
HOW CAN WE GIVE YOU
THE $100,000
FOR 20% WHEN WE CAN PROBABLY
PUT UP $150,000
AND OWN 100% OF IT?
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
Adriana:
WELL, I HAVE THE EXPERTISE.
I'M UP FOR NEGOTIATION.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE --
YOU HAVE EXPERTISE RUNNING
A CAFé WITH CATS IN IT?
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A LONG HISTORY
WITH CATS.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, MY GOD, I HAVE A FEELING
THAT'S NOT GONNA BE GOOD
'CAUSE YOU WANTED THEM
TO JUMP OUT OF A BUILDING.
NO, YOU'RE GONNA LIKE
THIS STORY. THANK
GOODNESS YOU'VE MET ME.
IN MY SECOND YEAR OF COLLEGE,
I WANTED TO BE A MARKETER,
SO I ENDED UP WITH A JOB
FOR MISS MEW CAT FOOD
AND DR. BALLARD'S DOG FOOD.
I GOT A LETTER FROM A WOMAN
WHO HAD A 23-YEAR-OLD CAT
NAMED FLUFFY.
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
FLUFFY HAD BEEN RAISED
HER ENTIRE LIFE
OFF DR. BALLARD'S DOG FOOD.
FLUFFY HAD NO HAIR LEFT,
NO TEETH.
AW, FLUFFY.
IT MADE ME REALIZE...
I DIDN'T REALLY LIKE CATS
THAT MUCH.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
I'LL STILL SECRETLY
LIKE YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELL, I THINK IT'S GREAT
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SAVE
AND RESCUE CATS.
I THINK IT'S
AN ADMIRABLE MISSION.
KEEP GOING WITH IT.
I'LL BE WATCHING,
BUT AT THE MOMENT, I'M OUT.
OKAY, NO PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
SO, ADRIANA, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
ON POINT
WITH WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU WANT
TO SAVE ANIMALS,
AND I WOULD LOVE TO DO
THIS DEAL WITH YOU,
BUT RIGHT NOW, AS A BUSINESS,
IT'S NOT THERE YET.
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
SO, I THINK PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO WANT
TO COME TO YOUR CAFé
THAT LOVE CATS,
AND IF YOU HAD ONE OF THESE
IN MY HOME TOWN,
I WOULD GO THERE
ALL THE TIME.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE IS,
IS IT'S A CONCEPT.
IT IS A CONCEPT.
AND SO, TO DAYMOND'S POINT,
ANY ONE OF US, IF WE THOUGHT
THIS WAS GREAT,
COULD GO FIND SOMEBODY
IN OUR HOMETOWN
TO GO PUT ONE TOGETHER
AS A CONCEPT STORE,
SEE HOW IT GOES,
AND THEN SCALE THE THING OUT.
SO, FOR THAT REASON...
I'M OUT.
BUT GO GET OUT A LOAN,
GO FIND A GREAT PLACE
WITH A GREAT LOCATION,
GOOD FOOT TRAFFIC,
AND I THINK YOU'LL SUCCEED,
AND I WISH YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
THIS IS REALLY A HOT SPOT.
IT IS A HOT SPOT.
MY WIFE AND KIDS
WOULD GO THERE
AT LEAST
A COUPLE TIMES A WEEK.
Adriana:
NOT GETTING A DEAL MEANS
THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE
A LITTLE BIT LONGER,
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHEN I OPEN A CAT CAFé
IN FLORIDA,
IT'S GONNA BE HUGE.
IT'S GONNA EXPLODE,
SO THEY REALLY MISSED OUT.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN INNOVATION
IN PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION.
OH, SWEET!
John:
NOW YOU'RE TALKING.
THAT'S AN INTRO.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M JOE WILCOX.
MY COMPANY IS SWAY MOTORSPORTS,
AND I'M SEEKING $300,000
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
THIS IS SWAY, A NEW ANGLE
ON TRANSPORTATION.
COMPACT, STYLISH, AND,
OF COURSE, ALL ELECTRIC,
SWAY IS THE THRILL
OF A MOTORCYCLE
WITH AN ADDED DEGREE OF SAFETY,
UTILITY, AND MANEUVERABILITY
THAT'LL MAKE IT THE PERFECT
URBAN COMMUTER.
THE SECRET IS THE PATENTED
SWAY-TILT CONTROL.
THIS IS AN ALL-MECHANICAL
LINKAGE
THAT I HAVE DESIGNED THAT ALLOWS
THE RIDER TO CONTROL THE TILT
OF THE VEHICLE
WITH THEIR FEET...
THAT'S VERY COOL.
...WHILE KEEPING BATTERY MASS
ULTRA-LOW
FOR MAXIMUM STABILITY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SWAY
IN ACTION.
SO, BECAUSE YOU CAN STEP
INTO TURNS DIRECTLY,
YOU CAN ENTER TURNS TIGHTER
AND TURN FASTER THAN YOU CAN
ON A TWO-WHEELER.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BALANCE THE VEHICLE,
YOU CAN CARRY PASSENGERS
AND CARGO,
AND UNLIKE A TWO-WHEELER,
YOU CAN RIDE THIS VEHICLE
ON SNOW, MUD, AND ICE,
AND YOU NEVER HAVE TO PUT
YOUR FEET DOWN AT A STOP
OR IN STOP-AND-GO TRAFFIC.
SO, SHARKS,
HAVE A SEAT AND BE SWAYED.
JOE, ARE YOU GONNA TELL US HOW
MUCH IT COSTS TO BUY A SWAY?
WE'RE SELLING ON OUR WEBSITE
FOR $79.99
FOR THE 60-MILE-AN-HOUR,
40-MILE RANGE VERSION.
DO I BUY THAT DIRECTLY FROM YOU,
OR IS THERE A DEALERSHIP
NETWORK?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS FIND
AN O.E.M. MANUFACTURER
WITH END-TO-END SUPPLY CHAIN
AND DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS,
SO IT WILL BE THROUGH
A DEALERSHIP,
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE NOW CHASING
A HIGH-VOLUME MANUFACTURER,
AND WE'RE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH SEVERAL HIGH-VOLUME
MANUFACTURERS
TO LICENSE THIS IDEA.
HOW MANY PREORDERS
HAVE YOU TAKEN?
WE NOW HAVE DEPOSITS
THAT REPRESENT OUR FIRST
$350,000 IN PRE-SALES.
AND WHEN DO YOU PLAN ON
DELIVERING THE FIRST UNITS?
AND SO, THAT'S REALLY WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY.
WE COULD BE TO MARKET
WITHIN A YEAR
WITH THE RIGHT
MANUFACTURER.
John:
DID YOU DESIGN THIS YOURSELF,
OR DID YOU GO TO ANOTHER MAKER
AND HAVE THEM PUT IT TOGETHER
FOR YOU?
NO, I'M A MAKER.
I'M A BUILDER.
FOR YEARS,
I'VE BEEN A TOY INVENTOR
AT IDEO IN PALO ALTO,
CALIFORNIA,
AND I'M CREATING AND DESIGNING
AND INVENTING
TOYS FOR LICENSE
WITHIN THE TOY INDUSTRY.
WHAT IS IDEO?
IDEO IS A GLOBAL DESIGN
CONSULTANCY
THAT DOES
USER-CENTERED DESIGN.
ONE OF THE TOP IN THE WORLD.
YOU CAN WALK THE HALLS
OF MAJOR TOY STORES TODAY
AND SEE MY WORK.
THIS IS LIKE
THE ULTIMATE TOY TO ME
FOR, YOU KNOW, MEN, WOMEN.
DO YOU NEED A MOTORCYCLE
OPERATING LICENSE
TO OPERATE THIS?
CALIFORNIA
AND THE EUROPEAN UNION,
BECAUSE IT HAS THREE WHEELS,
YOU DO NOT NEED A MOTORCYCLE
LICENSE TO RIDE SWAY.
HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE YOU INVESTED SO FAR
TO GET TO THIS PROTOTYPE?
TOTAL CAPITAL SPENT,
I WOULD SAY IT'S BETWEEN
$100,000 AND $200,000.
IMPRESSIVE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PATENTS?
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PATENTS
THAT WE'RE SUPER PROUD OF IS,
WE TAKE THE BATTERY MASS
OF THE VEHICLE
AND WE USE
THIS BOTTOM PLATFORM
AS AN INTEGRATED
STABLE STORAGE PLATFORM
IN WHICH BATTERIES, CHARGERS,
CONTROLLERS,
ALL OF THAT STUFF GOES --
SO THERE'S NO HARDWARE
IN THIS TOP PORTION.
THAT LEAVES IT OPEN
FOR STORAGE.
IT LEAVES IT OPEN
FOR HARDWARE ATTACHMENTS,
ALL KINDS OF
MODULAR ACCESSORIES.
SO, SORRY,
THAT'S A PATENT IS...
THAT'S A PATENT.
...PUTTING EVERYTHING
DOWN BELOW?
YES, SIR.
HOW HARD WOULD IT BE FOR SOMEONE
TO GET AROUND YOUR PATENTS
AND ACHIEVE
SOMETHING SIMILAR?
A LOT HARDER THAN WORKING
WITH US TO LICENSE IT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
LISTEN, YOU'RE A BRILLIANT
DESIGNER.
YOU HAVE A PROVEN TRACK RECORD.
OBVIOUSLY, WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS VERY INNOVATIVE,
AND IT'S INTERESTING.
THE MARKET
THAT YOU'RE GOING AFTER
HAS BEEN IN DEVELOPMENT NOW
FOR ABOUT A DECADE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS SORT OF
A BINARY DECISION FOR ME.
I BASICALLY BUY AN OPTION
FOR $300,000,
AND THEN I HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE
IF YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
IN GETTING
A DISTRIBUTION PARTNER,
A MARKETING PARTNER,
A MANUFACTURING PARTNER,
'CAUSE THE ONLY WAY I'LL EVER
GET MY CAPITAL BACK IS,
ALL THREE OF THOSE
COME TOGETHER.
AND THEN, ON TOP OF THAT,
THE MARKET HAS TO TAKE OFF.
WE'RE TALKING TO
OVER FIVE MANUFACTURERS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE INTERESTED
IN DOING THIS.
THEY'RE REVIEWING THIS.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
MM-HMM.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
UM...
YEAH, I THINK --
Woodman: I THINK
YOU GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
IT'S A BIG HURDLE TO DRIVE
AWARENESS OF THE ACCESSIBILITY,
HOW EASY IT IS TO RIDE,
'CAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL LOOK AT THIS
WHO WOULD BE INTIMIDATED
BY A MOTORCYCLE,
AND LOOKING AT THIS,
IT LOOKS INTIMIDATING.
I MEAN,
I LOOK AT IT, AND I SAY,
"SWEET, I WANT TO GO RIP
THIS THING."
MM-HMM.
BUT SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT ALREADY
GOING TO RIDE A MOTORCYCLE
ISN'T GONNA LOOK AT THIS
AND SAY, "OH, I'M ALL OVER IT."
GETTING THE CONSUMER TO SAY,
"AHA! THAT THING IS FOR ME"...
RIGHT.
...I THINK A LOT OF THOSE
CUSTOMERS WILL ALREADY BE
INCLINED TO RIDE A SCOOTER
OR RIDE A MOTORCYCLE,
AND YOU ASKED --
YEAH, THE "WOW" FACTOR,
ESPECIALLY IN SAN FRANCISCO --
ARE YOU KIDDING ME? --
EVERY LITTLE TECH KID --
YEAH,
BUT THAT'S SAN FRANCISCO.
THOSE OLD LADIES IN THE CASINOS
PLAYING THE PENNY SLOTS
WILL HAVE THESE THINGS
ALL DAY LONG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
JOE, ONE CHALLENGE I SEE IS,
OF COURSE, DISTRIBUTION.
THE NEXT CHALLENGE I SEE
IS MAINTENANCE.
YOU KNOW, THIS THING IS GONNA BE
PLAYED WITH A LOT,
AND HOW WILL PEOPLE BE ABLE
TO, YOU KNOW, GET THE PARTS?
WILL THEY BE ABLE
TO GET THE PARTS?
WHO MAINTAINS IT?
I THINK THERE'S
A LONG, HARD ROAD
TO SUCCESS WITH THIS,
SO I'M DEFINITELY A CUSTOMER,
BUT AS FOR AN INVESTOR,
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SELLING YOU ONE.
YOU REMIND ME OF EARLY DAYS
AT GoPro
WHERE I HAD
MY ORIGINAL INVENTION,
AND MY DREAM WAS TO LICENSE IT
TO ANOTHER COMPANY
SO THEY WOULD GO DO
ALL THE WORK,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
BUILD A BUSINESS AROUND MY IDEA.
I JUST HAD THE IDEA.
AND I ACTUALLY WAS IN
LICENSE TALKS WITH KODAK,
AND THEY BACKED OUT,
AND THEY DIDN'T LICENSE IT,
AND AT THE TIME,
I WAS DISAPPOINTED.
AND, BOY, WAS I LUCKY
THEY DIDN'T LICENSE IT
BECAUSE IT FORCED ME
TO GO BUILD GoPro,
AND THIS SEEMS SORT OF LIKE
A SIMILAR OPPORTUNITY.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
QUITE A BIT LESS MONEY
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL AS A LICENSE
THAN IF YOU BUILT
THE BUSINESS YOURSELF.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED
TO SELL THAT MANY...
RIGHT.
...FOR YOU TO MAKE A HANDSOME --
YEAH, BUT YOU DO NEED
THE CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
THE DIFFERENCE,
THOUGH, IS --
HE DOES, HE DOES,
BUT IF HE CAME IN HERE --
'CAUSE TAKING $200,000
AND BUILDING CAMERAS,
WHICH YOU WERE AMAZING
AT DOING, RIGHT?
YEAH.
$2,000 --
$200,000 DOESN'T GET HIM
THROUGH THE FIRST WAR.
WELL, IT GOT HIM THIS FAR,
SO HE'S OBVIOUSLY WICKED SMART.
RAISING THE CAPITAL
WON'T BE HARD.
THE HARD PART IS
GONNA BE TAKING THE TIME
TO BUILD THE BUSINESS THAT
HAS THE INFRASTRUCTURE...
ABSOLUTELY.
...TO GO DO ALL
THE THINGS YOU WANT.
YEAH, BUT, I MEAN --
ONE OF THE STRATEGIES IS TO FIND
A COMPANY THAT --
THAT, THROUGH LICENSING
OR JOINT VENTURE,
YOU KNOW, IS GOING
TO HELP FUND THIS...
BUYING YOU.
...WILL EVENTUALLY BUY US.
THAT'S WHERE
I AGREE WITH NICK
'CAUSE IF YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE IT ON...
AND DO IT, JUST DO IT.
THIS IS A VERY
BINARY PRODUCT.
YEAH.
IT'S EITHER A GRAND SLAM
OR IT'S NOTHING, RIGHT?
YEAH.
I LOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN, THE CHALLENGE IS,
ANYBODY'S GONNA TAKE MY CALL,
BUT I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SIT
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION
AND EXPLAIN IT.
I CAN GET INTO ALL THE WEEDS
ON TECH,
BUT I CAN'T GET INTO THE WEEDS
ON THIS,
AND SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
YEAH, I THINK -- I THINK
YOU'RE ONTO SOMETHING.
YOU'RE REALLY PASSIONATE.
YOU'RE WICKED SMART.
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
A VERY GOOD DESIGNER.
I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
REALLY CONSIDER
CONTINUING TO DO
WHAT YOU DO
AND THEN FIND PEOPLE
TO HELP YOU
BUILD A BUSINESS
AROUND YOURSELF
AND SLOWLY,
ORGANICALLY BUILD SOMETHING.
RIGHT.
BUT I'M OUT.
SO, THE GUY WHO WOULD GO RAD
AND HAM ON THIS THING IS OUT,
THAT'S HOW I GET PAID
FOR MY TIME.
BUT WE DO HAVE
THE QUEEN OF QVC...
WAITING IN THE WINGS.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, YEAH, THIS WILL GO GREAT
ON QVC.
OH, MY GOD!
O'Leary: NO, I SEE YOU --
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
A NICE GUY.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
YOU KNOW THAT I'M
IN RETAILERS EVERYWHERE,
AND I THINK IT'S PRETTY COOL.
I LIKE IT.
YEE-HAW!
I'M NOT SURE, YOU KNOW, WHAT
I COULD BRING TO THE TABLE
TO YOU BESIDES THE MONEY,
BESIDES MAYBE MAKING SOME CALLS
WHERE THEY WOULD ANSWER
THE PHONE, GET A CONNECTION.
YOU SEEM TO BE DOING A LOT
OF THAT YOURSELF.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY, SO -- SO, I MEAN,
JUST TO SPEAK
TO SOME OF THESE POINTS --
JOE, AT THIS POINT,
IT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE ALL
THE SHARKS ARE OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
JOE, LET ME
JUST TELL YOU THIS.
THERE HAVE BEEN PEOPLE
WHO HAVE STOOD THERE
WHO HAVE HAD SECOND CHANCES
TO COME BACK...
YEAH.
...BECAUSE THEY'VE TAKEN
THE PRODUCT
AND GOTTEN IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
ALL OF US HERE WOULD AT LEAST
CONSIDER BEING A CUSTOMER.
I KNOW I WOULD, RIGHT?
YEAH. I AM.
GET IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL
AND COME ON BACK.
I THINK WE ALL THINK
YOU'RE GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IS REALLY AWESOME.
SO, WHY NOT INVEST?
$300,000 IS THE FIGURE
THAT WE -- BINARY IS --
SUCCESS IS BINARY.
IF YOU WON'T INVEST $300,000
TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO WITH IT --
JOE, YOU GOT TO --
WAIT, WAIT.
SO -- SO, MAKE ME AN OFFER.
MAKE YOU AN OFFER?
RIGHT, KNOWING THAT IT'S
JUST MONEY, CASH MONEY,
'CAUSE I'M NOT -- I'LL PICK UP
THE PHONE IF I NEED TO,
BUT I DON'T KNOW THE INDUSTRY,
I DON'T KNOW THE PEOPLE.
OKAY, WE'LL GO -- WE WOULD GO
$300,000 FOR 20%.
DONE.
OH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THIS IS AN AWESOME VEHICLE.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S GREAT, MARK.
I LOVE YOU DID THAT.
I'M EXCITED.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE
PART OF AN INDUSTRY.
OH, WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT HAPPEN.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE BOOKOO BUCKS.
JOE, I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYBODY GIVE
THEMSELVES MOUTH TO MOUTH
THE WAY YOU JUST DID.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANKS, YOU GUYS.
CONGRATS, MAN.
TAKE IT EASY.
Woodman: WHEW!
WELL, I SHOULDN'T HAVE GONE 20%.
I SHOULD'VE GONE 15%.
BUT THAT'S -- THAT'S OKAY.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE GONNA
PULL THE PLUG ON ME.
WELL, THAT WAS INTERESTING,
MARK.
Grenier: THAT WAS GREAT.
IT WAS EASY.
IT WAS JUST A QUESTION OF, OKAY,
IF IT'S THE RIGHT AMOUNT,
THEN IT'S THE RISK/REWARD,
RIGHT?
BUT CAN I BUY ONE FROM YOU
AT A DISCOUNT?
NO. [ LAUGHS ]
THERE GOES YOUR GoPro.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HEY, I'M CHRIS RUDER,
AND MY COMPANY IS SPIKEBALL.
I'M HERE IN SAN DIEGO TODAY
FOR A SPIKEBALL TOURNAMENT.
WE GOT 45 TEAMS, AND THEY ARE
PSYCHED TO PLAY TODAY.
THE WAY I LIKE TO DESCRIBE
SPIKEBALL IS,
IF VOLLEYBALL AND FOUR SQUARE
HAD A BABY,
IT WOULD BE CALLED SPIKEBALL.
SPIKEBALL IS SO MUCH FUN
BECAUSE IT'S SO ACTIVE,
IT'S SO COMPETITIVE.
THERE'S STRATEGY,
A TON OF TRASH TALKING --
ABSOLUTE BLAST TO PLAY.
SPIKEBALL STARTED AS A FUN,
CASUAL BACKYARD GAME.
IT'S BECOMING
A COMPETITIVE SPORT,
ESPECIALLY ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THANKS FOR COMING, EVERYBODY!
SPIKEBALL!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
POTENTIAL FOR SPIKEBALL
IS LIMITLESS.
THERE WILL BE SPONSORS.
THERE WILL BE
PROFESSIONAL PLAYERS.
IT WILL BE THE NEXT GREAT
AMERICAN SPORT.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY THINK
I'M OFF MY ROCKER BY TALKING
LIKE THAT,
BUT WHEN WE STARTED
THIS COMPANY,
PEOPLE THOUGHT WE WERE CRAZY,
AS WELL,
AND LOOK WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL SPIKEBALL!
WE'RE HOPING TO BLOW
SPIKEBALL UP.
THE SHARKS, I BELIEVE,
CAN HELP US GET THERE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS CHRIS RUDER,
AND I'M FROM CHICAGO.
I'M HERE TODAY LOOKING FOR
AN INVESTMENT OF $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF MY COMPANY, SPIKEBALL.
SPIKEBALL IS POISED TO BE
THE NEXT GREAT AMERICAN SPORT.
LIKE ALL GREAT SPORTS,
SPIKEBALL IS VERY EASY TO LEARN
BUT REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT
TO MASTER.
IT CAN BE A CASUAL,
FUN BACKYARD GAME,
OR IT CAN BE HARD-CORE
COMPETITION.
ANOTHER GREAT THING IS,
SPIKEBALL IS ULTRA-PORTABLE.
SO, ALL YOU NEED IS THIS BALL,
THAT NET,
AND ONE OF THESE BACKPACKS,
AND YOU CAN TAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY ANYWHERE.
SO, STANDING TO MY RIGHT HERE
IN THE BLACK JERSEYS
IS CHICO SPIKEBALL.
THEY HAVE BEEN THE
NUMBER-ONE-RANKED TEAM
IN THE COUNTRY
FOR OVER 12 MONTHS.
THESE GUYS ARE JUST
ABSOLUTELY DOMINATING.
DOMINATING.
[ LAUGHS ]
THEY'RE GONNA PLAY A COUPLE
POINTS AGAINST TIRO UNITED.
NOW, YOU'RE GONNA SEE
IN A SECOND,
THEY'RE GONNA SERVE THE BALL
BASICALLY JUST BY BOUNCING IT
OFF THE NET TOWARDS TIRO.
NOW, JUST LIKE IN VOLLEYBALL,
TIRO HAS UP TO THREE HITS
BETWEEN EACH OTHER
BEFORE THEY HAVE TO SPIKE IT
BACK ON THE NET.
NOW, THEY, OF COURSE,
WANT TO SPIKE IT SO CHICO
CAN'T GET TO IT.
IF YOU CAN'T GET IT ON THE NET,
THE OTHER TEAM GETS A POINT.
FIRST TEAM TO 21 WINS.
ONCE THE BALL IS IN PLAY,
THERE ARE NO SIDES.
ALL FOUR PLAYERS CAN RUN
ABSOLUTELY ANYWHERE THEY WANT.
GENTLEMEN.
I'M GONNA ASK THE GUYS
TO COME OUT HERE
AND PLAY A COUPLE POINTS.
OH!
OHH!
AWESOME.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
WHO INVENTED THIS GAME --
YOU?
NO, BROUGHT IT BACK TO LIFE.
SO, IT WAS AROUND BACK IN 1989,
AND ONE OF MY GOOD FRIENDS
BOUGHT IT AT A TOY STORE,
AND THEY AND MY OLDER BROTHER
PLAYED A BUNCH
AND ABSOLUTELY LOVED IT.
AND ABOUT 10 YEARS AGO,
YOU KNOW,
THE LIGHT BULB KIND OF WENT OFF.
WE WENT HOME AND KIND OF
DID OUR HOMEWORK,
FOUND OUT THAT THE PRODUCT
HAD BEEN OFF THE MARKET
FOR LIKE 15, 20 YEARS.
SO, WHO OWNS SPIKEBALL?
WE DO.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
UH, THEIR RIGHTS
WERE COMPLETELY EXPIRED, SO --
AND YOU JUST RECLAIMED THEM?
THE TRADEMARK, YES.
THERE WAS NEVER A PATENT.
HAS IT EVER BEEN CONTESTED
NOW THAT IT'S SUCCESSFUL?
NO, AND WE ACTUALLY DID GET
A UTILITY PATENT.
THERE'S SOME GUY THAT'S
GONNA BE WATCHING THIS GOING,
"OH, MY GOODNESS."
YOU MENTIONED, OBVIOUSLY,
THAT IT'S A SPORT.
WHERE CAN YOU TAKE IT?
HOW BIG CAN IT BE?
IT CAN BE HUGE.
SO, WE'VE GOT A GOVERNING BODY
CALLED USA SPIKEBALL,
SO WE HAVE TOURNAMENTS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
HOW MANY TOURNAMENTS
ARE BEING PLAYED?
WE'LL HAVE ABOUT 100 TOURNAMENTS
THIS YEAR.
AND DO YOU CHARGE THEM?
IT'S "LOOSELY"
A FREEMIUM MODEL.
WE ALSO SELL MEMBERSHIPS.
AND HOW DID YOU --
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
HE SELLS MEMBERSHIPS.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
YEAH, SO, YOU CAN BUY
A "BALLER" MEMBERSHIP
ON USA SPIKEBALL.
WAIT, SAY THAT.
BALLER MEMBERSHIP.
ARE YOU ALL BALLERS?
Grenier:
OH, THAT'S MARK'S WORD.
OH, YEAH, OF COURSE.
BALLERS, BABY,
IN THE HOUSE!
Woodman:
WHAT'S THE DEMOGRAPHIC?
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE AGE
OF THE --
18 TO 24 MALE
IS OUR SWEET SPOT.
WHAT DOES ONE COST?
$59.99, PLUS SHIPPING.
CAN I GO TO A TOY STORE
AND BUY IT?
SOME TOY STORES, YES.
WE'RE FOCUSING MORE ON
SPORTING-GOODS STORES.
WE'VE BEEN AROUND
ABOUT SIX YEARS.
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS,
PURE E-COMMERCE.
CHRIS, HOW MANY UNITS
DO YOU SELL IN A YEAR?
THIS YEAR,
WE'VE SOLD 29,000 UNITS.
AND HOW MUCH DID THEY COST
TO MAKE?
UH, A LITTLE OVER $14
A UNIT.
SO, LAST YEAR,
YOUR TOTAL GROSS SALES?
$1.4 MILLION.
AND THIS YEAR, YOU EXPECT IT
TO BE AROUND 3...
BETWEEN 3.2 AND 3.5.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO BE KILLING IT,
THEN, BECAUSE IT'S ALL MARGIN,
SO WHAT ARE YOU -- WHAT ARE YOU
NETTING AT THE BOTTOM LINE?
SO, LAST YEAR, WE NETTED,
I WANT TO SAY,
ABOUT 170,000, 180,000 GRAND.
WHY SO LITTLE?
RETAIL'S GROWING LIKE CRAZY.
SO THAT TAKES YOUR MARGIN.
SO OUR E-COMMERCE
BUSINESS GOOD,
BUT RETAIL
IS REALLY EATING IN.
SO, HOW MUCH
ARE YOU PAYING YOURSELF?
UM, MY SALARY?
$175,000.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, THAT MAKES IT UP.
GOOD FOR YOU.
CAN I GO BACK TO ONE THING,
JUST THE PRICE?
SURE.
CAN YOU GET YOUR COSTS DOWN
FROM $14?
HAVE YOU TRIED THAT?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHERE DO YOU THINK
IT COULD GO TO?
UM, MY --
I'D LOVE TO GET IT DOWN
TO THE $10 RANGE.
John: CHRIS, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
USE THE MONEY FOR?
WORKING CAPITAL.
WE'RE STARTING TO GET
REALLY, REALLY BIG ORDERS
FROM REALLY BIG RETAILERS.
HOW BIG,
FROM WHO, FOR WHAT?
THE BIGGEST WE WORK WITH
IS DICK'S SPORTING GOODS.
WE'VE GOT P.O.s
FOR 10,000 UNITS TO SHIP.
HAVE YOU DONE ANY TESTS
WITH THEM
TO SEE HOW IT SELLS
THROUGH THE STORE?
YEAH. OUR INITIAL TEST
WAS 100 STORES.
YOU STARTED YOUR TEST
HOW LONG AGO?
UH, TWO MONTHS AGO.
DID THEY TAKE IT TO MORE STORES
EACH TIME?
WE'RE IN 250 NOW.
SO, WAIT, IN TWO MONTHS,
YOU'VE GONE FROM 100 TO 250?
YES.
OH, THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
AND JUST IN THAT BROWN BOX?
I MEAN, THAT WAS YOUR --
CAN I SEE THE BOX?
SO, PROBABLY WORD OF MOUTH
IS GETTING OUT THERE.
LET'S CALL IT A...
NOT A TOY BUSINESS,
BUT IT'S A...
IT'S A SPORT.
AMEN.
I DO NOT WANT
TO BE RELEGATED --
DO NOT SELL IT IN TOY STORES
'CAUSE YOU HAVE TO
PROTECT YOUR BRAND,
AND AS SOON AS IT SHOWS UP
THERE, YOU'RE JUST A GOOFY --
WOULD YOU SELL IT AT WALMART
IF THEY ASKED YOU?
MAYBE.
OKAY, SO, DUDE, DUDE,
SO, GoPro...
HUGE FAN.
WE DO EXTREMELY WELL
AT WALMART.
GOT IT. ALL RIGHT, THIS IS
THE EXPERTISE I NEED.
YEAH, I WOULD NOT SHY AWAY
FROM THAT OPPORTUNITY.
IF YOU ACTUALLY ACHIEVE
YOUR GOALS THIS YEAR,
YOU'LL DO ABOUT $320,000
TO $350,000 PRE-TAX.
YEAH.
YOU'RE ASKING ME TO PAY 20 TIMES
YOUR CASH FLOW
FOR A BALL AND A NET.
BALL AND A NET -- THAT'S KIND OF
LIKE CALLING YOUR BABY UGLY.
I MEAN, I LOVE IT.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE
THAN THAT.
HE JUST CALLED YOUR BABY UGLY.
LOOK, I THINK THE BUSINESS
IS WORTH
ABOUT SEVEN TIMES
THE CASH FLOW.
IT'S WORTH ABOUT
2.5 MILLION BUCKS.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
WOULD YOU DO A DEAL WITH A VALUE
LIKE THAT ON IT?
NO, I THINK THAT'S DISCOUNTING
IT WAY TOO MUCH.
WE HAVE SIX YEARS --
WELL, LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN --
I'M GONNA SIT BACK AND WATCH
AND SEE HOW ENTHUSIASTIC
ANOTHER SHARK MIGHT BE.
I THINK IT'S VERY CLEVER.
THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S VERY INTERESTING
WHAT YOU'VE DONE,
BUT NOT OFTEN DO I SAY I CAN'T
SEE MY WAY TO THE VALUATION,
BUT HERE IS ONE OF THESE
WHERE IT'S LIKE I JUST --
I DON'T SEE IT.
ALL RIGHT.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
LORI.
I'D SAY YOU'VE GOT
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO COST-REDUCE THIS THING.
I WOULDN'T BE TOO HUNG UP
ON YOUR $60 PRICE POINT...
OKAY.
...ESPECIALLY AS YOU MOVE
INTO LARGER RETAILERS.
ONE THING I'D LOVE FROM YOU,
IF I MAY --
IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT I CAN PERSONALLY
GET SUPER PASSIONATE ABOUT.
MM-HMM.
IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
LOOK, CHRIS, I'M GONNA BE
BRUTALLY HONEST WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU --
WHEN YOU WALKED IN,
I THOUGHT THIS WAS
GONNA BE STUPID.
IF YOU WOULD'VE BROUGHT THIS TO
ME AND JUST DESCRIBED THIS TO ME
AND SAID, "MARK,
WOULD YOU INVEST?
WE'RE GONNA TURN THIS
INTO $3 MILLION IN SALES.
DICK'S GONNA PLACE AN ORDER
FOR 10,000 UNITS"
ALL WITHIN A FEW YEARS...
I WOULD'VE SAID,
"STEP AWAY FROM THE BAR."
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN IF YOU WOULD'VE SAID
ON TOP OF THAT,
"YOU THINK THAT'S MAD?
WE'RE GONNA HAVE LEAGUES"...
ABSOLUTELY.
...I WOULD'VE SAID, "I'LL TAKE
WHAT YOU'RE DRINKING."
BUT YOU DIDN'T, RIGHT?
YOU'RE KILLING IT!
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I CAN'T SEE MY
WAY TO A $5 MILLION VALUATION.
I CAN'T.
OH, COME ON!
I CAN'T. RIGHT, CAN'T.
REALLY?
I CAN'T, I CAN'T, I -- I CAN'T.
I'M OUT.
OHH. OUCH.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
CHRIS ONLY HAS TWO MORE CHANCES
TO MAKE A DEAL FOR
HIS BACKYARD GAME, SPIKEBALL.
SO, CHRIS,
I'M IMPRESSED, OKAY?
I'M IMPRESSED IN YOUR
ARTICULATION OF THE BUSINESS
AND WHAT
YOU'VE ACHIEVED SO FAR.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE
ON THE VALUATION.
YOU'RE VERY, VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT BEING WORTH A LOT,
AND YOU'VE RUN INTO A LOT
OF ROADBLOCKS ALREADY.
ALL THE ENCOURAGEMENT FROM MARK,
AND THEN HE GOES OUT.
THAT'S JUST RIDICULOUS.
SO, HERE'S THE DEAL.
I'LL LOAN YOU $500,000
'CAUSE THIS BUSINESS CAN NOW
SUPPORT SOME DEBT.
I'LL TAKE THE 10% EQUITY
AS A WARRANT FOR DOING IT,
ALL RIGHT?
THE TERMS ON THE DEBT
ARE SIMPLE.
I'M GONNA CHARGE YOU 9%.
I'M GONNA WORK VERY HARD FOR YOU
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE THE 10%
COULD BE WORTH SOMETHING
IF YOU ACHIEVE SUCCESS,
AND THERE'S ENOUGH EVIDENCE HERE
THAT YOU'VE GOT A BIT
OF A VIRAL THING GOING ON,
WHICH I FIND VERY INTERESTING.
SO, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
UM, I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I'D LIKE TO SEE
IF DAYMOND...
CAN WE HAVE A CHAT?
VERY, VERY,
VERY SMART GUY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I HAVE THE SAME CONCERN THAT
MOST OF THE OTHER SHARKS HAVE.
THE EVALUATION
IS NOT SPIKEBALL.
IT'S BALLS WITH SPIKES.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU KNOW?
SO, HERE'S
WHAT I'M THINKING.
YOUR CHALLENGE IS
MAKING GOODS
AND PROVIDING THEM TO THE STORE,
ALL RIGHT?
YEP.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $500,000,
AND MY AGENDA WILL BE
TO TAKE THAT PAIN AWAY,
WHICH IS STARTING
TO DO LICENSING,
STARTING TO DO MANUFACTURING,
AND SHIPPING TO THE STORES.
MM-HMM.
THAT WOULD BE WHAT
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
FOR 25%
OF THE WHOLE COMPANY.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO RUN
THE SPORTS DIVISION.
YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO RUN THE ONLINE SALES
BECAUSE THAT'S CREATING
YOUR SPORTS DIVISION.
GOT IT. SO --
VALUE YOUR BUSINESS
AT $2 MILLION.
YES.
UM, SO, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THAT'S -- THAT'S QUITE RICH.
UM...
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 500K
AT 15%?
WE HAVE GOT THIS SNOWBALL
THAT IS ROLLING DOWNHILL
AND GETTING BIGGER
AND BIGGER.
WE'VE GOT AN ARMY
OF AMPLIFIERS --
SCHOOLS, RETAILERS.
BUT I GOT AN ARMY
OF AMPLIFIERS, TOO,
THAT WILL HELP YOU,
SO THAT'S GONNA COST ME ALONE
$200,000 THAT'S NOT PASSED ON
TO YOU.
YOU'RE SAYING YOU HAVE
NO FLEXIBILITY.
YOU'RE AT A CROSSROADS
RIGHT HERE
WHERE YOU HAVE
A VERY HIGH EVALUATION,
AND YOU'RE GETTING
A LITTLE GREEDY.
YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS
THAT YOU CAN LOSE IT ALL.
I'LL GO 22%.
CALL IT EVEN AT 20%?
WE'RE DONE.
ALL RIGHT. DONE.
YOU'RE KIDDING ME.
Cuban:
WAY TO NEGOTIATE, CHRIS.
AWESOME.
CONGRATS, BUDDY.
THANKS, GUYS.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS!
NOW YOU'RE INTO SPORTS, D.J.!
THANKS, GUYS.
[ ALL CHEERING ]
HAVING A PARTNER LIKE DAYMOND
JUST REALLY MAKES ALL THAT TIME
AND HARD WORK AND EFFORT
JUST REALLY WORTH IT,
AND, I MEAN,
JUST FEEL LIKE WE'RE ON THE TOP
OF EVEREST RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS JUST AWESOME.